дорогі вихователі і виховательки вчителі
і вчительки викладачі і викладачки Я
вдячний кожному і кожному
запрацьовитість наполегливість і
занезламність під час війни
освічена Україна - це наше майбутнє і
саме ви його створюєте ви не лише
навчаєте Нове покоління українців Ви
також формуєте у молоді національну
ідентичність прищеплюєте їм громадянську
свідомість розвиваєте критичне мислення
креативність толерантність допитливість
завдання якесь сьогодні стоїть перед
нашою командою допомогти вам змінити
систему таким чином щоб у центрі уваги
завжди залишалась людина дитина
вихователь вчитель викладач учений
у садочках ви формуєте у наших дітей
першого уявлення про світ у школі вчити
розв'язувати задачі і висловлювати свою
думку а студенти навчаються у вас
критично мислити та приймати складні
рішення своїм прикладом ви вже вихвалили
не одне покоління сміливих і рішучих
українців які сьогодні відважно
захищають свободу нашої держави нашу
незалежність наш суверенітет у
надзвичайно складних умовах ми рухаємося
уперед вихователі викладачів вчителі
педагоги та науковці ви рухаєте
Українську освіту і науку вперед вдячний
кожному і кожній і завдяки кому
українського освіта не просто вистояла а
продовжує розвиватися сил натхнення і
стійкості у новому навчальному році
нехай він стане переможним для нас усіх